Cory starts off this hour in Salt Lake
City hi Cory welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave how are you today better
than I deserve what's up good thank you
for the opportunity to be on your show I
really appreciate it so Dave my question
is um well little little bit of
background so my wife and I combined
income we take home about eighty six
thousand dollars a year and me and my
wife were new to your baby steps we have
about twelve thousand nine hundred
dollars in student loan debt and I have
recently taken an interest in software
coding my current job I I'm kind of
capped out in my income and I'd like to
make more but I need to go back to
school I found a software boot camp here
in Salt Lake City that is about fourteen
thousand nine hundred dollars for a
three week or three-month course to
learn coding my question is should I pay
off my student loans first and then save
up money to pay for the software boot
camp or put my my loans on hold save up
money and pay for this boot camp and and
and do that you make eighty six thousand
dollars a year household income yeah
yeah okay what did you do both in a year
yeah we can okay can more or less my
question is what should i do first
should I pay off my student loans first
and then save up and do that because
it's not delaying you if it was five
years delaying you to get to do your
thing
but it's delaying you six months okay
yeah go get your student loans knocked
out then save up the money and go to
school now the code the code school is
at night or day um it is a full-time day
course it's from 9 a.m. to 6 p.m. and
there's a quit your jobs well that was
another thing is yeah I'd have to save
up some money or work work night so what
do you make when you make it your job
what portion of the 86 is you 68
yeah yeah okay so I'm a I'm a technical
writer and there's just not a lot of job
growth here in Utah for that come
there's about seven great open positions
right now and and I'm actually in it how
much how much how much of that can you
do freelance I've done a little bit of
freelance I made about four thousand
dollars last year freelance about that
dried up I'd have to find another
another contract that's that's an option
to I think I would find three contracts
to do while you're in school okay before
you quit your job and go to school okay
because I the most disturbing math part
of this whole discussion is sixty eight
seventy thousand of your eighty-six is
going away that sounds like starvation
yeah you've got to have that covered
okay some way or another how's your
family going to eat during this time
unless somebody wants to hire you before
you have finished code school and pay
you while you're in code school but the
detail I didn't think about I'd have to
worry about that yeah somehow we've got
to cover that three months of food okay
and yeah it could be three contracts or
laying there and you're doing your
technical writing weekends and nights
while you go to school during the day I
think you'll get employed very quickly
coming out of code school is my guess
yeah there's pretty much a shortage out
there and what I mean what which
language are you thinking of learning
well this code school they teach
JavaScript and I believe it's nodejs
yeah something else all right job Java
scripts pretty popular I mean we've got
some of those folks on team we got a
bunch of Ruby folks on team and you know
that I think just based as an employer
in the marketplace hiring people that
that should get you landed in a position
very quickly once you come out of code
school I might want to have that lined
up though okay I don't want to come out
and then start my job search okay you
know at least I'll have a
for warm leads of where I'm gonna go to
work upon completion all four of them
expressing interest saying hey call us
when you get out we think we'll put you
on in the meantime you've got some
technical writing gigs and again once
you learn the code and it'll be better
to get on with somebody it's gonna be a
little tough to do it freelance when you
got no experience but but I'm just
trying to make sure your family eats at
the end of the story before you land in
the big JavaScript job okay from the
time you quit your job until you land a
post code school in that that gap that
three months plus gettinghired gap is
scaring me if you got that covered then
yeah I would pay off my debt and then
I'd say about my 14 and I would go do it
I think it's a good move I like the
overall move and it's the direction I
would go but you've just got to think
through the pieces of it so you don't
leave a hole in there and it derail your
your plan turn your plan into a night
your dream into a nightmare